good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to our planning committee
meeting today as there are no additional
health and safety measures that we need
to be made aware of let's move straight
to the agenda
item one apologies for absence the first
item we have received any in advance yes
uh we received apologies from council
william armitage who's substituted by
councillor pass ancliff
councillor mark foster who's substituted
by councillor steve clough
and councillor roger hall who's not
substituted thank you chair thank you i
don't think there are anybody else
missing
and no chair thank you
item two declarations of interest the
second item is the declaration of
interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interest and or
other interests
not already on their register of
interests in any item on the agenda and
withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
and on the siege thank you
oh i've lost a page
[Music]
minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 18th of january 2022
are we happy that they are a correct
record richard thank you is there a
seconder
thank you
all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
the motion's been carried thank you
this brings us to the main business of
the meeting we have five substantial
items each with its own report i am
happy with this and intend to consider
them
in that order
the meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube
however the stream will end when we
consider the two exempt reports
if any public are still in the room at
that point they will also be asked to
leave
before we begin i would like the clerk
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on youtube
how we will deal with the application
right thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
applications this afternoon
we will consider the two applications in
the order that they are set out on the
agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers ward members objectors
supporters then the applicant or their
agent
to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there will be reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary to clarify any
points they have made
when we have heard from all of the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee and
determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
once the application which your speaker
has come to speak on has been dealt with
they may leave the chamber or the zoom
meeting room
if they choose to remain then they will
not be allowed to participate further
from that point
now as you are aware this meeting is
being live streamed and recording will
be placed on the council's website
please note that others
may choose to copy it
thank you chair
thank you
the first application is item four which
is ned forward slash two one four slash
zero one two one one six tpo clay cross
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please rever reserve any
points of order or questions about the
process until the end there will be
plenty of time for questions thank you
i'm now going to invite the first
officer
yes thank you chair
just in in terms of this application as
you've outlined the application is
trying to take works to various trees
covered by northeast derbyshire district
council tree preservation order 276 at
clay cross
and further to the discussion that uh
planning site visits yesterday share the
application site comprises trees roughly
within the area at the center of the
slide here and the remainder of the site
to the east is the area that's currently
being developed for housing
to the grant of planning consent
the
proposals chair relate to the removal of
two trees these are the two outlined in
red
some works
to
the five trees outlined in yellow then
some more general works to raise the
crown of the trees within the two areas
hatched in
orange just those two areas
the cursor chair
let's say the area to the east is the
area that's granted plenty consent for
essential development
just very briefly share and services
yesterday members did see um photos of
the trees but just to brief reminder
that two trees are relating to the
installation of some drainage works and
this is one of those trees chained the
others that we saw on the site visits
yesterday
thank you
thank you adrian i've just got one quick
question before i open the floor um i
was sent an email with some photographs
yesterday do we have these on site
the there are some photographs shared
that relate to the application
representations made those they were
sent out in the late representation
yesterday there has been various other
correspondence that has been
submitted
more in relation to the the general
nature of the development of the site
sharing concerns over the weekend
further to the heavy rainfall
so the late reps yesterday specifically
refers to the comments we've had about
the the trees and the the application
before this afternoon
thank you so we've not received any
footage of photographs or video
yes there have been
footage of um as i say the um brook
further to the heavy rainfall open last
few days and comments in remains in
relation to wider flooding issues chair
but nothing and as far as i've read it
in relation to this application of them
to that information that's in the late
representations that were sent out
yesterday
thank you adrian
i believe we have some speakers for this
application and the first speaker i
believe is councillor ross shipman who's
requested to speak as a member who
submitted the original calling
council shipment three minutes when
you're ready thank you chair um i'm
quite disappointed to adrian they don't
think the video you've just referred to
chair and the
images that were sent out and not in
relation
to this application given the fact that
in the pictures where it's flooded as we
saw on sunday
some of these very trees that are being
considered during this debate are
actually in them
the trees act as a natural flood defense
for that brook and they were as far as i
could believe and understand they're
actually put in for that purpose to help
as a natural flood defense for the brook
so i think the video which i've got on
and if you've been sent it you should
have it on your own airpods to look at
yourself
is relevant and i think by passing this
and removing more trees
um from the side of that brook
is going to be a disaster
i think if you look at the photos and
especially the video where you see how
hard the water is
you see it's a real problem
and if the other side of the brook had
not been raised already
the other side of the brook would have
been flooded at the weekend
but because of that they've raised it
you can't tell from the from these
pictures but you come from the older
pictures the older pictures during the
first um time it was discussed and i'm
honestly really surprised that like i
say adrian or any of the other planning
officers have not brought it to your
attention because i think it's very
relevant
and under in this constitution under the
protocols of planning i think it's 9.2
any new information that's brought to
light
should be given its fair time to be
discussed at this meeting
so i'm concerned actually there's
applying officers saying it's not
relevant when clearly as you've just
highlighted you felt it was relevant to
even raise it at this meeting and i
think that planning officers even need
to get these photos in this video upon
screen or it's deferred until every
single person that sat around this
committee can actually look at it and
look at what you're voting for because
it was flooded the press brought nearly
broke its banks on sunday it was that
high
um and i believe that every single
committee member need to actually look
at those pictures and the footage in
order to make an informed decision today
thank you yeah
um before you leave were any properties
actually flooded they weren't but like i
said the level actually if you looked at
the level of where it got to
it was high it was it was higher than
the natural level that was on the other
side of the brook and but luckily it
didn't break its bank on sunday but it
was very close yeah the highest it's
been in years actually i think
considering the adverse weather we've
had over the last few days i think
anyone near a brook stream or river had
more than adequate concerns but thank
you
are there any questions for councillor
shipman
uh i have i have a question if i'm
allowed i'm another speaker junker no
you're not allowed
no all right sorry
okay thank you councillorship thank you
our next speaker is an objector mr
richard eden
thank you chair three minutes when
you're ready
yeah just like to make you aware yes
obviously on sunday we did have concerns
we had to ring your emergency services
out because we've got vulnerable
persons on windermere road what a bed
band downstairs
our electric meters are under the stairs
so if any water comes into that house
there's this risk of electrocution
i'd just like to say that adrian said
that the trees in the red
they have already been moved two weeks
ago
the developer did move them with an
excavator which was
not up to legislation they were supposed
to be moving them by hand because of the
otters and the waterfalls
we have got video footage of that
the previous damaged trees they was done
by the developer and it was
only down to the residents challenging
them and
enforcement
gaining touch reinforcement that they
were stopped from removing them and
that's why the original tpo was put on
these trees what they're on about are
within the 10 meter buffer zone
i feel they just wanted to trim the
trees to try and claim some more of the
buffer zone which is going to affect the
wildlife which they've already affected
with removing all the trees in the
orchard
but these trees were put there for a
reason
to to secure that bank side and also
absorb water if you allow them to prune
these
they're not going to absorb as much
water and it's going to put us at
further flood risk which we already have
been put out with raising of the land
uh we've got many concerns i keep coming
to these meetings and we just feel that
i'm banging me out against the wall but
we were the closest we've ever been to
flooding on sunday i know there was
adverse weather conditions
but the water was not allowed to go into
that floodplain because that land's been
raised and it increased the depth of
that brook it's only a matter of time
that we flood and this is down to that
development
i'm hoping that you'll all get together
today and and
not agree to these trees being
pruned back
uh
the developer
said they'd enhance the orchard
uh
which they didn't they removed every
single tree in that orchard there is not
one fruit tree left in that orchard
and you've seen this some wind damage to
the trees over the last previous days
and that's because they're out in the
open now because they've got no
protection because they've removed every
other tree that there is
on on that land uh they also haven't put
the active mitigation fencing is like
they stated it should have been in
before construction started
uh so
they're saying they need to put a fence
in but they've already got iris fencing
in so they don't need to trim the trees
because they can get iris fencing in so
they can get fencing and they just want
to take a bit more land i think anyway
thank you
thank you you'd like to stay where you
are just in case there's any questions
have we got any questions for speaker
councillor hancock
thank you chad just one mistreatment i
just want to clarify that i heard you
correctly did you say these two trees
have already been removed oh yeah the
red ones yes thank you they've moved
them with an excavator and they should
have done it if there was allowed to
move then legislation stated by wildlife
that any work on that bank had to be
done by and by until because of the
otters and the waterfalls and they have
done it by an excavator
thank you mr eden
and the third speaker mr john kirk he's
a supporter and he's speaking soon
hello yeah hello three minutes when
you're ready
um firstly i'm supporting the
application because um it appears that
apart from the drainage
the trees were being removed or have
been removed for the drainage
the application was obviously approved
and as part of that is the drainage
obviously a very very important part
um and
in my experience having installed
attenuation tanks and drainage systems
that are being installed on site i think
the actual flood risk will lessen and i
think seven trent's report backed that
up um
mainly for the reasons is that field has
already always drained directly into the
river and now
the flood water is gonna
contain into the attenuation tanks and
draining slowly so
i think the flood risk personally
downstream if there was going to be an
extra
element of flood risk would be
the case however
for the estate and for the trees i i
disagree um i live on the same road i
live on windermere road
um and the water was very high however
i've seen it quite a bit higher than it
was um this weekend
um
even though we've had terrible weather
it like say i'm not i'm not saying it
wasn't right the water rises very very
quickly and drains away very quickly
quickly and i think if there was
concerns and people that have concerns
if they actually remove trees
from the river further down the river it
had helped the flow of water so i don't
think personally
i think flooding the risk of flooding is
going to get better whether they trim
the trees or not
and my second point is um when the tpo
was in my opinion hastily put on these
trees was the condition of the trees
checked
sufficiently
just in light of recent winds i mean
there's no leaves on the trees um and
you've got a decent sized branch that's
probably going to fall on someone's
garden
um once these hours is a bill causing
risk to health or property um and you've
got some larger trees there that are
basically growing at a near 45 degree
angle towards the new houses so i don't
actually think they're going far enough
i think there's going to be more
requests to trim trees and i think if
you do not let the contractor trim trees
you're not letting them comply with the
cdm regulations which is
to remove any foreseeable risk and if
you can't see
from recent days that them trees are
causing foreseeable risk to them
properties and people
um
then i think you need to revisit the
site i think there needs to be more
trimming of trees and i think they
should be planting of semi-mature
and different species of trees along
that bank to make sure the bank's stable
however i don't think the trees
concerned
are in a very good condition and i think
they should be trimmed more
thank you
are there any questions
yeah that's it thank you
no thank you very much
and our final speaker is darren abbott
the applicant
are you with us mr abbott
yes i think so i any minutes when you're
ready
thank you
good afternoon and uh thank you for the
opportunity to address the committee
today my name is darren abbott recently
appointed planning director at woodhall
homes for the applicant seeking approval
for the proposed tree management works
as detailed in the office of
presentation planning permission was
granted for residential development of
this site and the details are supported
by an agricultural assessment which
forms an approved document listed on the
decision notice
many of the trees along the western
boundary lean heavily into the site and
have low crowns such as facilitating
works were envisaged from the onset and
referenced in the approved arbicultural
assessment
this document details access
facilitation pruning which essentially
covers instances where wide or tall
plant operates within close proximity to
the trees and allows for limited surgery
to prevent damage whilst this document
is approved such works are yet to be
undertaken today given the imposition of
the troops tree preservation order it's
clear that these works are required to
enable the development to proceed and
remedial work undertaken and such that
formal approval is sought
further details were
proved last year of a mitigation
strategy required by conditions the
planning permission prepares an
installation of fencing to protect and
segregate the wild buffer from the
development site again given the
imposition of the tree preservation
order these works could not be
implemented
approved agricultural assessment
a comprehensive landscaping scheme along
with associated management and
maintenance is approved for the site and
this includes planting of existing gaps
along the brook i note that no
objections have been received by the
council's tree warden or park box
officer and with reference to the trees
that have already been removed this was
with specific consent from the council
did their removal and hence they have
only been removed um with the consensual
from the council ahead of this meeting
i would welcome your supporting backing
your office recommendation to allow
these management words to proceed given
the submission of this application it
was in october last year thank you
thank you are there any questions for
the speaker
councillor elliot
thank you chad
i read in 5.2 about the otter fencing
can you tell me whether that's been put
in before you before you've started with
you
yes there's um
there's there's
security fencing up at the moment no
i've said otter fence inside yeah
there's security fencing up at the
moment but we haven't been able to get
the otter pre-fencing because we're
required to crown lift the trees but we
can't crown lift the trees until we have
consent formally from the council given
the imposition of the tree preservation
order it was originally envisioned that
would need to do that work within the
agricultural assessment but given that
there's an order in place we need formal
approval from the council to be able to
carry out those works
was that not stated in the original uh
report agricultural report yes yes it
was
about about putting in the otter fence
here i'm not talking about crowning the
trees
trees have been there a long time yeah
the octoproof uh fencing is in the
ultimate application strategy which is
an approved document approved by a
condition in october last year and is
the condition did we not state the
condition was to put that in before you
started development of the site
that is a well it's a regulatory point
on that planning condition but we can't
get it in without crown lifting those
trees because of the the tree
preservation order can you tell me the
height of the utter feminism
it is not specified in the um mitigation
strategy but it talks about a harry's
fencing with um a gravel board at the
bottom temporarily coupled there after
with a gravel board and a permanent
fence and moving forward once
is completed so if you can educate me
the harris fencing as that needed posts
putting in
they are um temporary posts at the
moment with the security fences in place
and there is a mesh there but in order
to to to ensure that it is fit for
purpose we need to crown lift those
trees
the temporary posts and the temporary
fencing have been put in without crown
lifting but you can't put the utter
fence in before you crown lift
is that right that's correct that's the
case can you tell me exactly why
we could we simply can't get to the to
the place where we need to put the other
pre-fencing in order to segregate the
development site from the um from the
wildlife buffer
and if you could just tell me also
um in in the original um application
although now you stay you're talking
about removing trees on the original
application did it actually state
anywhere that you're going to start
putting more in
it's
putting more back it's in the it's in
the landscape construction yes we're
filling in existing gaps and we're also
got an approved landscaping scheme for
the orchard that was referenced too
the orchard that should have stayed
there
no none of the orchard has been removed
that that isn't this isn't shown for
removal it's all in the approved
landscaping scheme that's the council
has agreed to well i think i've sat
through a couple of these meetings on
this project on this development and
it's been stated on more than a couple
of occasions that the orchard had been
removed can you tell me that
everything i've heard is wrong then so
the orchard wasn't removed
i'm not aware of the orchard being
removed to the extent that it doesn't
conform with the landscaping scheme that
has been agreed
thank you chad
thank you are there any further
questions councillor hancock than
councillor [ __ ]
thank you chair um i'm just actually
trying to clarify on on the the council
elliot was i think trying to get you to
expand on which which you didn't really
um given that the height of this fencing
was never stated previously
then there clearly hasn't been a defined
need for these trees to be
for the crowns to be raised so i think
the point is why are you not actually
going with the height of fencing that
doesn't need work on these trees well
the height of the fencing for the for
the permanent structures is uh 1.8 to 2
meters in height so the boundary
enclosures
to the to the plots
so those will require crown lifting
which is as i say set out in the
approved agricultural assessment the
there is temporary fencing in the moment
but to ensure that it is that is to a
greater extent fit for purpose we need
to crown with those those trees as has
been um set up by our agricultural
consultant
yeah i'm sorry i'm still not clear on
why because
it's not making sense if you've got one
fence there that's pretty much the same
height and the pole wide at least why do
they need to be crowned to get the same
height defense in there there's this
these will be permanent structures once
the once the enclosures are a a
a place within the where the garden
areas will be for these plots
as opposed to the temporary fencing
that's in place at the moment
yeah i'm sorry i i don't know if i'm
being really thick or you just not
because one fence is another one that if
you're not needing to remove it for one
i really don't see why you need to read
it to the other you're not getting
across to me why there's such a need for
that to happen
because those will be permanent
structures that have been put in place
along the boundary of those of those
properties and along the site edge
rather than temporary fencing that is
being put in place at the moment
so the temporary fencing is not
physically attached to the ground
councillor liquor well unfortunately i
was going to ask the same question i was
going to ask
what the physical
difference is what if you can explain to
us exactly
how this fencing is going to be put in
and why
is different to the harris fencing it
would need machinery to be put in to go
into those areas
within the the well beneath the crowns
of the trees
we've all put fancy in at home without
machinery
well that's
lots of people put fencing against other
people's boundaries and they've only
been allowed to put fencing in from one
side they've not had access to the other
side that's what
i just can't physically get my head
around it the equipment is required to
to install those fencing but that is the
information that is before us and that's
the advice that we've had from our
agricultural consortium to prevent
damage to those trees we need to crown
lift those um along that boundary to
unable to get the the fencing in place
rather than the temporary security
fencing that's there at the moment
councilor elliot
thank you chair
and we're talking about the trees that
have gone uh and now i've read in in
some reporting some some of the late
reports that
you weren't supposed to be using
machinery to fetch those trees out would
you like to make a comment on that as
well
the
head wall that has been put in place um
is
ultimately dictated to the removal of
those trees and again that is approved i
don't know the method that um that that
has been put in place but i understand
that um that for that helpful there
obviously is agreed management of the
wild buffer and um the um the means of
doing that i i'm not aware of at this
point in time but we are adhering to the
um the management strategy that has been
discharged by condition
no longer
is the attenuation tank working now
the
relief tank
yeah
that's that's being installed
and that was
it working now i mean we've had three
days of quite severe flooding is it
actually working now and does it does
the whole thing drain into it and it's
not
the same it's not installed at the
moment no and that is just to be clear
that was provided as a gesture of
goodwill following discussions with with
local residents the concerns they raised
but the issue of flood risk has been
well exhausted through discussion and no
objections have been raised from the
llfa in that regard or the environment
agency the tank will go in it will be
it's a condition on the section 73
application but it's not in the present
so so
just correct me if i'm wrong you just
said it's in but it's not worth it it's
not it it's not been installed yet yes
right
thank you
are there any further questions
no thank you very much
okay now just come in just very briefly
on the issue that was raised by um
councillor shipman when and the address
committee i've just checked through the
emails that
have been received and many members have
received these emails over the weekend
and last friday i believe
and the emails from mr allen and mr eden
i've just reread them chair they are
referenced back to the application for
residential development not the one
before you this afternoon
and they do as members will have read
and seen they do relate as far as i read
it entirely to issues of flooding and
not
to matters of content for the
application before you this afternoon so
i've rechecked them chair and i'm
comfortable that the wording has to say
the the reference is back to the
application for residential
development alum and region
had over the weekend in relation to
potential flooding of their properties
thank you
adrian would it be possible to bring up
the site plan
so we can ascertain where this altered
is whether it's still there or not there
so we can put this to bed
just bear with me a second i'll just
reshare my screen
if you orchard chair as far as i
recall it was this area
further to the east of the site
and the application site as i say is
this western edge of the site that the
orchard related to these
number of these trees here chair which
not all
i believe comprised the area of the
former orchard there were various
trees in the state of
repairing that area but this is the area
of food as the orchard
or at least a part of that
adrian is there any pictures more up to
date than that one
of the sorry it really shows the trees
where i've got people here that live
there are telling me it's no longer
there so i just need to know for myself
where these trees are or not much
that much of this area it's difficult on
the aerial
photograph chair to show coverage and
detail of that but the the majority of
these trees yes have are no longer there
there's a rump along the eastern
boundary and i don't have a
site plan
easily at hand of the site i can
locate one if and she's like
we'll take a few minutes to get that
okay no problem
um i'm now going to uh
open the floor for members to put
questions to the offices but what i
would like to do is this proceedings
we have to focus on getting the clarity
about the points that you are not sure
of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we have heard and read and
i would be grateful if you could not
move any emotions at this stage and
let's wait until we've had a chance to
make our own assessment
councillor ridgeway
um yeah i'm i'm just um wanting some
information apparently we're sitting
here to determine about chopping down
two trees
um but we've already been told that
you've that you know they've been given
permission to chop these trees down
so i'd like to know
did the officers know about this
and when was the permission given for it
yeah that issue is addressed in the
report on page 27
respect the two trees in particular need
to be
felled as you can
recall on the
site plan the two trees that needed to
be removed were in relation to the
outfall of the drainage area
and they fell within that area and miss
travis and confirmed that to you very
recently so
as set out in the report at base 27
share offices of the view that
actually
those two trees don't require wouldn't
have required the consent of the council
in any case to be failed
we've made that clear in our reports you
because they were
they were reasonably necessary to
implement the approved scheme
thank you either council cooper then
councillor hancock
thank you chet
adrian just just moving on from that um
once again i've earned this afternoon
that those trees that have been removed
were removed
mechanically
but that shouldn't have been the case
can you enlighten us on that please
i'm not unfortunate at the moment chad
if you just give me a few moments i will
just check in terms of the the details
as i say may will be the point that
in terms of the removal of those trees
they they could have been removed anyway
but i will if um you're able to just
give me a couple of seconds to just
check the
that permission that which i think
counselor is referring to
um
whilst we are waiting for adrian i think
if people look at page 28 at the top
it does state whilst included within
this application the works do not
require the formal consent of the
council
yeah just as a point of order why has it
even been brought this way then because
they're paying for an application that
they've already taken decisions on and
they're doing it
because it was called in
excuse me chair that was the
that was the reason i brought it up
because it's actually stated that we're
here going to be debating about these
trees being chopped down so why why we
why is it even on the planning in here
when it's already been done
i couldn't agree more
i think we'll just wait for adrian to
come back with what he said but please
bear that in mind
i'll just share just a little bit of the
heighty
slowness of this end and
poor fingers
and
i'm almost there now
just having a look at the
relevant decision notice
which i think is what councilor cooper
is
is raising
i can't see
a condition chair that requires only
non-mechanical means to be used
to undertake any works
i'd expected to be in the
ecology section
there's an issue about a condition about
no vegetation clearance taking place for
you march and august
i think really we can move on i think we
can all from what i'm picking up around
the table that as the trees are already
gone we we need just to move on now to
the second part of the uh
application which is regarding the
condition and the pruning of the trees
otherwise i think we're just sitting
here twiddling our thumbs and wasting a
lot of time that we needn't have been
here for to do
so are there any questions to uh
council hancock
thank you chair it's it's on on 7 14.
concerns have been raised regarding the
works and the impact of flooding however
the tree works proposed pruning and
officers don't consider that these works
would have any significant impact on the
flooding issues raised
i'm basically wanting to know under what
qualification because every bit of
scientific evidence which includes
reports of the government of commission
from cambridge demonstrate that pruning
and
crowning of trees
actually has significant
impact on the amount of water that they
take up certainly for a period of two to
three growing seasons
jerry the issue as far as officers are
concerned is the
view of officers is that the works
proposed are minimal in extent
in terms of the the crown lifting two to
three meters
and also the removal of the few limbs
that are specifically addressed chair
and there may be a marginal impact on
transpiration for example but the trees
of the two that need to be removed will
remain
on site and the element of removal and
pruning that is proposed is an officer's
opinion and limited and minimal chair
and won't have any significant impact on
transpiration
and therefore the ability of the trees
to obtain water
thank you are there any further
questions
councillor jones
yeah i'm concerned that when we're
getting through to the beginning there
was
damage done to the trees not the big
trees those are trees that are now going
to be pruned but there were
damage done by the developers how did
that happen
they allowed that member to land at the
time
again chair um works on site were
um
the tree preservation order wasn't
placed on the the trees of the initial
stage chair i think as you you heard
this afternoon from
mr eden he did say that some of the work
was done prior to the trees being
protected formerly by the the tpo chain
i believe that
is a likely scenario in this instance
notwithstanding that chair even if an
element of this work was done to
undertake works in relation to the site
and i think it's a good point that the
works to
implement the permission would result in
some works being necessitated to the
trees in any case chair
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you
thank you to the officers and this leads
us into the final part of the process
our discussion about what we've heard
what we think and what we would like to
decide but before we go any further i
would like the clerk to remind us all
about motions
yes thank you chair
please vote in my members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that amendment will be voted on
if
first
motion is to be moved which goes against
the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false
in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timing of the motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair
thank you i'm going to open the floor
for debate
has anyone got anything to say
councillor hancock councillor elliot
then councillor liggett
i i'm going to raise and i hope it will
record in the minutes my concern that
every bit on this actual site seems to
be coming to us retrospectively because
they're just plowing ahead and doing
what they want to do and then coming and
saying oh we've done this can we get it
approved and and that is not the way
planning is supposed to operate and i'm
quite appalled um in terms of this
specific application
um the evidence that i've seen which as
i say is a cambridge report commissioned
for the government
even moderates amount of proving have a
dis pruning have a disproportionate
effect on a tree's ability to absorb
water
um so i i actually can't sport it but
the reality is they're going to do what
they want to do anyway so
how we move is is almost irrelevant but
thanks chair
councillor elliot no no
yeah council liggett
i was only a bit bit shocked really the
agent didn't seem to know anything about
uh otter fencing and i would have
thought you need to know about it so you
know how to put it all
that was one thing and also yes we've
got reports about the trees we don't
seem to have any ecology report
regarding
what damage could happen to the otters
and the waterfalls
because that's taking away some of their
habitat
i think that was covered when the
original application went in so it
wouldn't be applicable to this
unfortunately however we have had two
quite comprehensive reports one from the
tree warden at clay cross itself and one
from our own walden
and unless any of us are
equally or
like-minded experienced
i've got to go with what their reports
saying and their recommendations
i'd rather see this work carried out
properly and with recommendations in
place that tree planting is reinstated
and it is done properly with the proper
trees we want
does the developer um
say who is going to
try to crown lift these trees and so on
or do we
i think we can look at that that would
have to be part of the condition that's
something i'd have to clarify with
adrian
i'm reading through each air as well and
we've nowhere to move because apparently
this is all in the original application
but the only thing we can do is
stipulate who does the crown lifting and
to what degree as opposed to throttling
it back i mean i look at some of those
and they are they are just you know
there's things that have self-set a lot
of them not all of them but a lot of
them
but for me
and you know how iron with trees if you
fetch one out you put three back and
it's the trees and the roots that will
support those banks
and they're fetching them out
willy-nilly in my book
aj can i come back to you do we know
who's doing the crowning work
it would be done by the um
appointed
agent for the developer's chair just in
this case the
the application was made by
um not by the developers themselves but
by
an appointed agent i believe so somebody
who's got experience of tree work so it
would be done by somebody with our boro
cultural experience and not just by the
contractors
and would we have any way to monitor
that
we would monitor as any planning consent
chair we would need to ensure that the
approval if granted consent was
implemented in accordance with any
commission granted in this case chair
the the agent um the gentleman called mr
owen of eco tree co limited
um i've no
experience often but um certainly the
report that
came in with the the scheme did suggest
that the the trees have been properly
surveyed and as you say
it has been then assessed by our own
um colleagues and the tree warden at
play cross to give clarity to that chair
we couldn't say who should do it but in
this instance it would be um the
application has been submitted by
somebody with our experience i believe
and so you would expect it would be done
in the appropriate way sensitive to the
trees
any other
comments to be made
councilman
powell and i think um
it's very unfortunate that the
developer hasn't come across
particularly well
with lack of information
um
some might say disingenuous but
maybe i shouldn't say that
um i don't think we have a choice i
think we've got to approve it but i
would certainly make sure that
we say that the trees have got to be
pruned by a professional
tree surgeon
and not by a developer with an excavator
which seems to have been what's happened
already
um and i think we should
also look at replacing some of the trees
with a more suitable species
certainly uh
um
to follow our own tree policy that the
council has about native species
uh i would only
vote for it if those conditions were put
on
thank you
thank you council anchor councillor
jones
i'm concerned about the nesting birds
because we come into march very quickly
i'm not sure what date in march is but
it is in march that they're no longer
able to
cut trees that have got birds nested
can we make sure that that is followed
and inspected to make sure that it
doesn't happen after the date when it's
to be stopped
i think that can be part of the
condition because i believe it's the end
of march
that they can't do any further
work so i'm going to ask for a motion to
be put on the table
oh sorry councillor ridgeway yeah i was
just going to say i i totally agree with
councillor powell i think it's really
sad we've got no option on this but i do
think you know whatever trees are
chopped down like council eliot says i
don't want one tree i want three trees
for every one
and i think we need to be aware if
they're just chopping trees down which
they have done um that these trees are
crowned and that they are not suddenly
chopped down because
um they're getting in the way and i
think we need to really make sure that
we're very vigorous with the conditions
that we put on this
thank you i think we're all in agreement
with that and so i'm going to put motion
on the table i mean we really have no
other course of action as to actually
grant permission but with the conditions
that have been specified
so chad that was the conditions uh that
the work should be carried out by a
professional tree surgeon
um that the replacement of some trees
should take place which was in line with
the council's own tree policy so native
species
and then also in terms of the date of
when the work can take place so that it
doesn't affect uh nesting birds
is that the essence of it members
i believe
if i may just comment very briefly and
be advised by
jim if he feels this is an appropriate
advice chair but i
don't believe it's
appropriate within our gift to require a
particular person or body to undertake
the works
and but i do think we can require as two
trees are being removed i think it
reasonable to
require the replacement of those two
trees chair albeit members will be aware
that there is an approved landscaping
scheme already in place on the site
which will involve some additional tree
planting but um i do think it's
appropriate to place conditions on
requiring two replacement trees if you
feel that that's appropriate and also
there could be a requirement no works
undertaken during the bird nesting
season but i don't think it would be
um within our gift to require a person a
particular person to undertake the works
as the conditions and what is proposed
are quite clearly set out in the report
in the submissions chair
counselor elliot
adrian's absolutely right i just thought
we may be able to specify who does it if
we can't then i think i think we really
do need to supervise it or at least keep
her you know a check on what's going on
there and
and they have fetched the two trees out
i don't know whether we can stipulate
they put more back and what i don't want
to see go back is a sapling i won't see
a mature tree go back
not something that's going to take
another 15 years to get to two foot eye
now i think one of the conditions should
definitely be a
semi-maturity if nothing else
certainly not saplings council hancock
thanks chair what can we actually put in
adrian that would protect because i've
got concerns with what we've seen
already that it's going to be a complete
botched job if we've not got some
professional person undertaking it so i
think in order for me to vote in favor
of this we need something that will
actually ensure that it's going to be
done by a qualified person
first of all i'd rather chair the um the
submission is made by mr owen of eco
trico
mr abbott who they may appoint but he's
listening to this i'm sure taking heed
of that also chair as far as i read the
application it's very clear very clear
indeed what books are proposed and
that's spelt out in the application
details so
again i'm happy that we can
appropriately supervise as necessary the
works that need to be taken
and taking place should consent be
granted and
i do believe it's reasonable to require
two replacement trees to replace those
two that are being fell but and just to
reiterate to members that it is only
those two trees that are to be removed
other than that it is and limited crown
lifting and
um
pruning and remedial works has set out
in the application chair
okay
the questions thank you councillor jones
uh just to say is it possible for us to
take photographs of it now
and proceeding take more photographs so
we can actually see what is actually
happening
and and if it's been done in order as we
want it done
we do have a photographic chair of the
the trees as this time we saw those at
the site yesterday so
you know i'm comfortable that we have
that information and we can ensure that
the works
and granted treasury grant consensus
actually are undertaken
thank you
any further council [ __ ]
yeah i'm just a bit concerned because
mentioned before one tree out three put
back
all adrian keeps saying replacing with
two trees surely it should be six
if um members feel the chair that's the
only um
condition that they would require to
grant consent and they feel that's
reasonable that is
within your gift chair
thank you i think that's what we've
agreed if one comes out three go back
and i definitely want semi-maturities
going back in there
so it's to replace the two trees with
six semi mature trees um in line with
the council's tree policy so in other
words of native species
and then the second thing which i think
you've still agreed to is the
restrictions in terms of when the work
can take place so it doesn't impact on
nesting birds yes thank you
are we
ready to proceed emotions on the table
that we
have no option but to accept this and
move it forward with our recommendations
i'll second it chair providing all those
uh conditions are met thank you
i'm now going to go for roll call
thank you chair he could clearly state
for against or abstain counselor and
cliff
for
councillor club
four councillor cooper
councillor elliott
councillor hancock
council hearts on
casa jones
council liggett for councillor powell
councillor ridgeway
cassarouse
and councillor for unanimous chair thank
you adrian can i ask that as and when
the work reports come in that i get a
copy of them please
sure
thank you
thank you all very much and we can move
on to the second application
you can find my notes i know where it is
thank you
and the next application is ned forward
slash two one four slash zero one three
eight seven four slash fl at killer
marsh
again in line with a normal practice i'm
going to ask planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports which have been
produced and give a brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
i'll allow the officers to complete
their presentation
before any questions thank you
thank you chair there are no late uh
representations on this application
chair it is a an application seeking to
amend previously granted consent 21 at
least zero zero eight three four which
will allow for
room
state of one of the bungalows previously
granted consent chair and we saw
any of these slides yesterday at the
site
inspection meeting but the site
is at the center of the slide chaired
has extended consent for 13 bungalows
outlined in red as you can see on the
slide
and the site plan was approved and
consent is as you see there
and the site plan has proposed and the
only addition is the addition of some
deluxe windows in some of the internal
facing roof slopes
just in terms of the detecting chair
this is um house type c which has
consent and you'll be able to see that
the difference is
apologies the rooms in the roof space
which is this area here so
the outline and the detail of the
building and all openings other than the
installation of the
roof lights on the internal roof
roof
slopes all the other details of the
application remain unaltered
and then just in terms of the house type
d again chair and the only alteration is
the provision of rooms in the roof space
just just through here that's a
reminder photograph that's a little site
visit yesterday of the site and the
transparent trail shown beyond the trees
here
the bungalows you're located in this
area here you can see that properties
beyond the site to the north and across
the road to the east
this area where the photograph's taken
from chair is uh footpath leading to a
bridge of the promens penine trail thank
you
thank you
and i believe we have one speaker this
afternoon the daniel baldwin speaking by
zoo
mr balor are you there oh yes i could do
it three minutes when you're ready
lovely um
well as clarified by the planning
officer uh we've currently got
permission for 13 bungalows on the site
that's two runs of four terraces two
blocks of semis and one detached
this application is simply seeking to
reconfigure the four mid terrace
dwellings
um
it involves moving one of the ground
floor bedrooms up onto the first floor
the existing bedroom downstairs will be
turned into the staircase that it's um
up to the loft bedroom so
to clarify
the bedrooms already approved it's three
bed dwellings and the proposed is for
three bed dwellings so there's no
increase in number of bedrooms
uh i noted some increased uh concern
regarding parking um
the approved parking is
staying exactly as is on the proposed
there's two parking spaces for each of
the dwellings so that's 26 spaces in
total for the site
um just to be clear the current volume
scale massing and size of each dwelling
is staying exactly as is
we are simply accommodating a new
bedroom in the already approved loft
space
and external appearance is staying
exactly as is apart from as mentioned
by the case officer uh the addition of
some values windows which face into
uh the adjace
the internal roof space
and that's all i've got to say
thank you are there any questions
council club
thank you chair uh just the question
that residents have raised on the
original image images of the properties
is showing a roof light in every single
building and a window coming out of the
roof space
is this going to be the case or is it
just going to be on the four properties
that you want to increase
we've got approval to have them windows
there then windows are already on the
improved scheme so
they're no different um
those windows are high level windows in
voltage spaces for the properties that
um
don't have the benefit of having a
bedroom upstairs um so then windows are
there on every property and we're there
on every property on the approved scheme
that we've already got
so it will there be a veloce window in
each property as well
as shown on the site plan
you can see that every property already
has two developed windows in and that's
over a vaulted living space um
the four properties in question on this
application
we'll have the additional developed
windows
for
uh likes to the bedroom that has been
moved upstairs
so is there is there likely to be a
future plan to increase
uh further 1.5 in the other laws
absolutely
are there any further questions
thank you mr ball
sorry oh sorry councillor hancock thank
you chad it's just a point of clarity
just for my own my own peace of mind the
way i'm looking at these plans there's
actually no increased overlooking as a
result at all it's simply overlooking
somebody else's roof isn't it that
starts here yeah
yeah that's correct thank you
any further questions no thank you mr
bull thank you
have we reached the point where are
there any questions for the planning
officers
no not good
oh okay got light off there little
flightly there asian okay we'll move on
then to i'll open the floor for debate
if there's any
no i think we'll just then move straight
on to uh emotion
thank you
all right okay thank you very much roll
call then
thank you chair uh counselor and clear
for councillor clough
for councillor cooper
councillor elliott
councillor hancock
council hearts on four cancer jones
councillor liggett for councillor powell
councillor ridgeway
council rouse
and councillor clough
for
unanimous chair thank you
thank you all very much and we can move
on then to
the
planning and appeals lodged and
determined
they've been moved by councillor elliot
the seconder thank you councillor
hancock everyone else in favor
thank you very much
i have no matters of the urgency but now
we move on to item nine exclusion of the
public
that the public be excluded from the
meeting during this discussion following
the item of business to avoid disclosure
of them of exempt information
i don't think anyone's left on it
oh sorry i have to read the rest
okay
i'm trying to do my bit
uh defined in paragraph three part one
of schedule 12a to the local government
act 1972
as amended by the local government
access of information variation order
2008.
do we all agree to take that
yup everyone happy thank you very much
you